[Music]
the Star Wars universe that we see in so
long it was different from anything else
that we've seen in a previous Star Wars
movies the Empire controls everything
everyone is struggling to survive but we
discovered this incredibly free spirit
we're meeting Han right before he
becomes the Han that we know you end up
getting to see how this guy got to be
the way she is it's all part of this
great expansion of the Han Solo world
it's a rite of passage you look at the
tests he needs to face the challenges he
asked to endure to become unsold
those first encounters with Chewbacca
you're gonna be the nickname cuz I ain't
saying that every time with the
Millennium Falcon
with Lando Calrissian did you win your
ship playing cards I like this kid there
in this movie I'm a driver a great pilot
he's the most exciting character in the
saga for me you don't know what he's
gonna do I'm a terrible person he's
reckless does these stupid things that
should never work
[Music]
and they do I thought he doesn't was
bravado
that might be the only person who knows
what you really are
what's her
[Music]
you're after something
[Music]
is it revenge
[Music]
money
or is it something else look good little
rough around the edges but good heard
about a job big shot gangster putting
together crew
I'm a driver and I'm a flier
I waited a long time for a shot like
this what do you think well what do you
know you got a line on a ship
yeah no guy either by smuggle around I
heard a story about you I was wondering
if it's true everything you've heard
about me it's true l-3 let's go with the
mean man's face hey these guys
if you come with us you're in this life
for good
might wanna buckle up baby
[Music]
let me give you some advice
assume everyone will betray you and
you'll never be disappointed I got a
really good feeling about this
since when do you know how to fly me 190
years old look great
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]